well in the last few moments there have
just been a few updates from the Polish
president Duda he says it's highly
probable the rocket was used by
Ukrainian air defense he says nothing
proves there was an intentional attack
on Poland uh going on to say we have no
proof now it was launched by Russia so
certainly a diplomatic rowing back of
language from the Polish president the
investigation that's going on he says is
being conducted by Poland and by NATO it
was probably in his words an unfortunate
incident
well earlier the U.S President Joe Biden
said he thought it was unlikely the
missile was fired by Russia
it's unlikely
that was fired from Russia
we'll see
toe response from our Europe
correspondent Adam Parsons but first of
Cordelia Lynch at the G20 Summit in Bali
and I suppose a certain amount of panic
there initially Cordelia are at the
summit a lot of rescheduling a lot of
emergency talks but it now appears that
this looks like it could have been some
kind of as in the Polish prime
minister's words an unfortunate accident
yeah it certainly does Jane I think
what's been interesting and watching
events unfold and the responses here in
Bali is that there is quite a difference
between the reaction from Joe Biden who
very soon after the news started coming
out uh was suggesting pouring some doubt
on the notion that this could have been
a Russian attack we later had sourcing
from various U.S officials that they
believed this came from Ukraine Rishi
sunak though taking a different position
I see he said that he would await the
investigation but irrespective of where
this came from or the intention they
needed to recognize the threat posed by
Russia and I think that is because they
see this as a an opportunity for
momentum for consensus to raise the kind
of collective voice here against Moscow
and to send a direct message to Vladimir
Putin this is a complicated nuanced
thing then we have heard from Dimitri
peskov the Kremlin spokesperson who's
actually praised Joe Biden's response
saying it was restrained and
professional by contrast he's referred
to the Polish response and that of other
countries as hysterical but look Rishi
sunak taking this opportunity his first
big moment big test on the world stage
to make clear exactly where he stands on
the Russian invasion of Ukraine
something he has consistently over the
past few days referred to as a barbaric
War
Cordelia thanks very much well let's
talk now to our Europe correspondent
Adam Parsons and Adam we've just heard
from the Polish president that may not
now be necessary in his words to uh get
NATO to implement Article 4 procedure
but we are going to hear from the NATO
Secretary General in a short while
aren't we
yeah Jen stoltenberg will be talking
here at NATO headquarters and I think
that this is a delicate time for the
organization we go back to last night
and there was of course this immediate
heat around the suggestion that Russian
missiles had landed on polish territory
important to remember Poland is a member
of NATO and the treaties of NATO say
that an attack on one member is an
attack on them all so anything that
looks like a potential Act of aggression
against a NATO member so it's all sorts
of alarm bells ringing there were at
that time a lot of people who were
saying to me we have to wait for this
investigation I think there were a few
moving Parts number one was that Poland
in recent time has been taking an
extremely aggressive stance in calling
for more action to stop Russia and the
second thing is I think a nervousness
about jumping into this bridge Article 5
isn't triggered like that it stood need
it requires the approval of NATO members
to to put it into action same with the
article for an article 4 is a mechanism
that a state can bring into play and say
right we need to have an emergency
meeting well by coincidence ambassadors
were meeting here anyway they're clearly
today this morning have been discussing
what happened in Poland the latest
information they had I think bearing in
mind that it's now apparent or seems
apparent that this was missile was fired
by Ukrainian air defense the idea of of
invoking article 4 now seems pointless
and as you said uh Polish president
Andre Duda has now said that they have
no evidence that this missile came from
Russia it would appear to have been a
Ukrainian air defense missile that was
fired at one of the Russian missiles and
somehow ended up Landing in Poland
Russia saying that none of its missiles
were within 35 kilometers of the
Ukrainian border well I I'm no expert on
on missiles but presumably an air
defense missile that misses that Russian
projectile could have landed just over
the Ukrainian Polish border that is what
they will be investigating so I think
NATO and other nations have now pivoted
away from this act and saying well this
is in a sense emblematic of the fact
that if Russia keeps maintaining this
level of aggression firing somewhere
between 80 and 100 missiles into Ukraine
that not only is that devastating for
Ukraine but that it invites this sort of
error this sort of uh unwitting
escalation and that that is another
reason for a the world to call on Russia
to back down and B for NATO to consider
putting more of its assets potentially
air defense systems into Poland and
indeed increasing its support for
Ukraine so I think in a sense we've gone
from a discussion about this particular
incident to a separate discussion about
where NATO stands with Ukraine and how
it response to this apparent increase in
Russian aggression